hi welcome to how more people tell you
go to hell
here we welcome you I'm in hell and I
did it all without any tech from 2019
why the hell did I end up in hell oh
well it's actually quite simple
as the clock nears 2020 I've been
thinking a lot about how much the
smartphone has changed the world and us
in the last decade so I challenge myself
to live with just 2010 tech first 24
hours I asked my producer penny for some
suggestions on where to go I think you
should go to hell
Michigan I grew up near there and so we
got to packing I gathered a bunch of
gadgets I used in 2010 yeah I'm bringing
my BlackBerry Bold 9700 Zune HD a flip
Mino HD a Canon point-and-shoot and a
Garmin Nuvi for GPS all of them
surprisingly worked after I charged up
the batteries okay I am putting this
iPhone in this drawer at my house and
I'm leaving it here for the next 24
hours or so challenge one get to heaven
and took off for the airport to begin a
series of four challenges Kenny had
designed for me how it turns out is a
small Township about 60 miles out of
Detroit
drive to stay at a hotel nearby and then
another drive to help the flight part
was easier than I thought
what could all these people on their
phones no ticket on my phone nothing to
really do while killing time in line
this is a prick breaker it's so good I
was so good at this no streaming music
or movies 21 degrees Fahrenheit
the driving part not as easy here
no GPS it thinks we are in Wisconsin
we're not it was content these are in
Wisconsin still turns out that Garmin
didn't have the latest software update
which needs to be downloaded on a
Windows computer to reach the damn
satellites so I went back to 2000 but it
looks like we've got to take 94 out of
Detroit
the maps got me close but not close
enough I had to call the hotel for
directions
[Music]
I'm so happy right now
the Holiday Inn Express in Howell which
is close to hell tomorrow we will go to
hell
I asked the concierge to print me out
directions from Powell to hell they
never get the help
this past night
I have been looking for Darwin for quite
a long time
get ice here before hell freezes over
and this is its challenge complete
challenge to post a selfie on Instagram
I really would like my head to block the
pure try this again nope nope
[Music]
ah
myself the game was not good in 2010
okay
now how to get these photos onto
Instagram she'll be a challenge
is there an internet cafe in hell I may
need to use the Wi-Fi on my blackberry
wasn't gonna help since Instagram
doesn't have a BlackBerry app so I
hooked up the camera to my new friend
Vaughn's Windows PC I'm gonna import
them then I got to googling carat
weight.this seems like a hack I finally
figured out a way a google chrome trick
for developers that lets you force your
web browser to be like a phone's web
browser yeah that's good hello from hell
I did it challenge I feel pretty good
I'm also starving challenge 3 review
lunch
on Yelp it's slim pickings on
restaurants in heaven so I opted for the
hell hole bar and I ordered a local
favorite so I'm gonna be eating a Patsy
Patsy Patsy what is it called this is
called a pasty this is a Michigan
delicacy I'm eating a pasty and it looks
like a cross between chicken pot pie and
an empanada
now posting my review was well not
really possible there was very little 3G
service in the restaurant right the
browser will load but I can't really
search on the blackberry either the
bigger issue was that the BlackBerry 5
browser was so slow to load images and
the site and yes the iPhone 4 was out in
2010 but I still had a blackberry it was
only hours later while sitting on the
plane back home that I was able to log
in and post it challenge complete it
don't get me wrong most of my day in
hell was hell am I even in the photo but
in many ways it ended up being like
heaven I don't even want to take a photo
of this so that's that good it was nice
remembering how we used to do things
like navigate the world with our brains
or ask people to take photos of us best
of all it was nice to remember when
social media feeds were just on
computers and unable to distract us
everywhere we are and back from how and
here it is I've made it my iPhone would
I do it again how much waiting some hell